[Music]
Luke dominate here with the outdoor boys
YouTube channel and today we're about to
go on a three-day fishing adventure are
you guys ready yeah
well Rebekkah my wife is that a big
conference for about a week and she took
Jacob with her so me Tom and Nate are
just some wild bachelors here and we're
going to spend this time going on a
little adventure we're gonna go down to
Smith Mountain Lake and we're gonna see
we can't do a little fishing and filmy
and just have a great time now we're
gonna eat a lot of ice cream yeah can we
get three small ice cream cones
[Music]
yeah we can come check it out got
ourselves a little room for the boys and
check out this view but we were gonna be
filming right down there in this docks
we're gonna come down the boys are gonna
get a swim and we're gonna do fishing
videos all tomorrow and probably the
next day ease Oh take and put your
clothes away okay put your clothes in
these drawers
alright the pizza's here guys you ready
all right guys let's go check out the
dock and get some bait out there oh well
it's late we got the boys to bed but
we're gonna do a lot of fishing tomorrow
all right I think we need to go do some
fishing all right guys here watch little
paw patrol eat a little pizza get some
breakfast
Luke dominate here with the catfish and
carp YouTube channel and we are doing
the 50 pound bluegill challenge that's
right well we've been out fishing all
day in the Sun and now we're getting
some dinner just kind of relax a little
bit and as Sun gets low here we're gonna
go and hit it some more and this time
maybe do some catfish or carp fish I'm
good this let's eat that is a big old
grasshopper you want to see them fly if
they fly well all right guys I go get
some Chinese food they're like Chinese
taquitos green beans rice chicken and
noodles that's my style
look at all that sugar Oh
so we've got some slightly crusty panco
sweet corn jello bait here and I've been
chumming this spot up for a day now
we're gonna see if we can't catch
ourselves the Cartman well it's getting
late and we haven't had any bites on the
catfish of the carb gear but I'm really
proud of Tom he's out there fishing in
the dark with his headlamp for bluegill
just laser focus that he's really
getting into it yeah but I think we
better get these boys to bed welcome to
the last day of our adventure here we're
getting dressed and trying to go find
ourselves some breakfast and we're
taking a little slim-jim break get some
breakfast a single can take some
time to overpower its victims you got
big bellies oh yeah well we're done with
breakfast and the boys want to go
fishing so fishing we shall go Nate you
bait in your own hook good for you in
every limb up reel him up Nate just use
your reel oh yeah this is nice I'm not
fussing about filming much just relaxing
well we caught some bluegill but it's
time to start packing it up oh man we
crash hotel rooms like rock stars
[Music]
all right we're gonna take a little road
trip break here get some food and ice
cream at the MU through hey then
whatever ice cream you won you guys like
your ice cream oh yeah dark chocolate or
full of ice cream and Tommy's made some
new friends but we got to get going
yeah there's been a fun trip well guys
we finally made it home we hope you
enjoyed this video as much as we enjoyed
making it if you want to see more videos
from the outdoor boys YouTube channel
don't forget to click subscribe thanks
for watching
if you like this video don't forget to
check out the outdoor boys YouTube
channel where we have hundreds of videos
just like this and don't forget to click
subscribe so you can see other great
videos every Saturday morning and hit
that Bell button so you'll get
notifications thanks for watching
[Music]